thank you very much for coming
it's very nice of you all to come out on
a friday afternoon
i'm thrilled to see so many familiar
faces
here in the room um with me
um i'm steve petty i'm professor of
history and american studies and i
direct ethnicity race and migration here
at yale
and i'm the master of ezra styles
college and it's really an honor
to play a a small role in the
inauguration of peter salovey
and in that capacity to get a chance to
share some of my work with you
when cesar estrada
died
in late april of 1993
more than 20 years ago at age 66
immediate words of praise and reverence
were heard from many though not quite
all sectors of the united states chavez
passed away in his sleep not far from
his childhood home in southern arizona
where he'd been born to land owning
parents
in 1927 and where he was then in 1993
helping to defend the united farm
workers union which he directed for more
than 30 years against a lawsuit by the
bruce church corporation
caesar's son-in-law arturo rodriguez who
has served as the united farm worker's
president since 1993
caught the news about chavez's death
while listening to rario campesina the
radio station which the union had
founded during the 1970s
caesar's son paul chavez reached
longtime union vice president dolores
huerta in salinas on the phone
who rushed to the local ufw office to
share the news
distraught workers organized a mass at
sacred heart church that afternoon
guided by huerta's injunction that they
emphasize quote
caesar's life being a celebration and
one of non-violence and one of peace to
turn this into a positive thing
the press stories that broke later that
day and over the following days included
emotional tributes from dozens of labor
and civil rights leaders who'd worked
with chavez over the decades
president clinton called him quote an
inspiring fighter and an authentic hero
to millions of people throughout the
world and the following year in 1994
bestowed upon him posthumously the
presidential medal
of uh freedom
from california and oregon and
washington state
to idaho and missouri and maryland and
washington dc
the last 20 years have seen many
monuments to cesar chavez many efforts
to remember him by my count 14 parks
25 streets seven libraries 46 schools 10
buildings on college campuses
and one unincorporated town on the u.s
mexico border all named after him
the renaming of these public signs
has been in many places a hard-fought
battle but in general it's proven far
easier for americans to deal with the
dead caesar than it was for them to deal
with the living
now of course discussions of the united
farm workers legacy since chavez's death
have coincided with a major demographic
latinization of the united states over
the last 34 years from something like
14.6 million latinos in the u.s in 1980
to around 52 million as of 2011.
even most of the united farm workers
detractors in 1993 on the moment of
chavez's death made nice
for at least a brief moment
in the in the season of the funeral
with the spokesman for california's
grape workers and farmers coalition
telling the press
that quote caesar was a tough and
tenacious individual who fought for what
he believed in
we respected his perseverance and the
president of bruce church with whom the
farmworkers were then fighting in the
courts registering quote appreciation
for his spirit in what he did
even conservative republican california
governor pete wilson ordered that the
state capitol fly its flags at half-mast
in memory of chavez so dissonant voices
stayed mostly quiet with just a few
exceptions
quote i think his legacy is very little
announced long-time union support union
opponent john jamara a grower in the
central valley the ufw hasn't played
much of a role for more than 20 years
now my own perspective is different than
john jamara's not surprisingly
and in a sense may take off from the
work of critics like mexico's carlos
monsieurs who's long reminded readers to
pay attention to those who quote ejersen
la democracia de este habajo icin per
per permiso those who exert democracy
from below without asking for permission
in the process expanding their rights by
exercising them
what follows then today is my effort to
think through some themes just a few of
them that lie at the heart of some of my
recent work in mexican-american history
that attempt to reckon with our new
appreciation
for the varying roles that the united
farm workers and chavez have played in
the political spheres of the 20th and
21st century u.s
and that focus in particular
on religiosity
prompted in part here by the ecumenical
coalitions that formed around latino
labor and civil rights
demands since the 1990s as churches have
really have led the way
in recent years in calling for more
humane approach for example to
immigration reform
so it's my argument today
that chavez did exert democracy from
below
in monster vice's phrase and that he
made expansive political demands by
bringing religiosity into the farm labor
struggle in new ways
over the last 50 years american politics
has developed in part because of that
emphasis of chavez's during his lifetime
it was for this reason that upon
chavez's death
ufw supporters and others drew immediate
comparisons between caesar and other
fallen leaders
a form of veneration that was more in
their eyes forward-looking than it was
backward looking
many were anxious in 1993 that the ufw
had been built on chavez's charismatic
leadership
and what would they do now
he had been the union's sole president
for the entirety of its 31-year history
and although he'd exerted great energy
in the 1960s and the 1970s turning down
individual awards and emphasizing that
no single leader defined the farmworker
movement the 15 years prior to his death
had seen him concentrate more and more
power and authority in his and in his
family's hands
in making sense of the president's death
union and civil rights leaders
and workers themselves were forced to
reckon with questions of succession and
about the nature of the farmworker
movement itself
moving forward in april 1993
those who stepped in to lead the united
farm workers built on established ways
of harnessing death for political
purposes among california's
mexican-americans in particular
an approach that chavez had had himself
helped to define in previous decades
martyrs and prophets have long played
important ideological roles in civil
rights
as a leading california activist during
the 1950s
chavez had literally
wrapped the caskets of returning korean
war soldiers in the mantle of the
community service organization the group
that chavez helped to lead and defound
in california during the 1950s
as a leader of the united farm workers
union after 1962
he subsequently made fellow activists
who died on picket lines into union
heroes
establishing during the late 1970s for
example that august 16th and january
24th would be set aside as annual
holidays for the union and declaring
that a memorial mass would be held in
the martyrs memories at each union
convention every year
it was within this movement culture
that many in 1993 declared with hope
that chavez now dead would continue to
play a fundamental role in social
justice work in the future and that his
spirit would continue to unite working
people
one farmworker at the funeral was heard
to say quote
dead
no sir
his body died but caesar chavez is alive
here look in all of these people and all
of the farm workers we are cesar chavez
it was in this spirit
that chavez was likened to martyrs and
to prophets worldwide
san jose's enrique dominguez and many
others immediately called him our martin
luther king
he was our gandhi said democratic state
senator art torres
when his body arrived at the union's
headquarters in la paz california not
far from bakersfield the following day a
crowd lined the gates of the ufw
property to sing movement songs
500 friends and family members attended
a mass that night on that property
including notables like martin sheen who
flew in
from pennsylvania where he'd been making
the film gettysburg
prior to the beginning of the service
union officer david martinez
pulled the priest from the local
tehachapi diocese aside and provided a
suggestion
for the homily that night
quote
it's real important
that the people remember that jesus
didn't establish the church
jesus recruited organized taught and set
him up and showed them the way
everything they needed to know
and when he died
they're the ones that went out and built
that church
and that's their charge now
the union's foundation is laid
but they're going to have to go and
build it
prompted in this way the priest indeed
delivered the message about caesar the
prophet
allowing huerta and others in the union
leadership to emphasize in turn that the
union would
continue tens of thousands of people
turned up to the funeral itself
volunteers had flocked to the town of
delano in central california to help the
union organize the funeral service
within hours of caesar's death some
brought lawn mowers and beat up hoes to
make parking lots out of overgrown
fields groups of women brought scissors
and thread to make ufw flags
farm workers abandoned california field
and orchard jobs and ray ramirez a
50-year-old ex-united automobile worker
member from milpitas california in the
bay area spoke for many urban residents
when he told the press that quote i come
from the fields i have to identify with
these people
bronx congressman not far from here jose
serrano drew attention to chavez's
importance to quote the puerto rican
field laborers in the east and to
industrial workers everywhere
while television personality hedaldo
rivera
called the ufw president the most
important latino of the 20th century
the funeral itself became i think the
largest such ritual ever held for a
labor leader in u.s history
twelve thousand attended the rosary held
for chavez
and some two thousand kept vigil
overnight to watch the sun rise over his
casket in advance of the burial
chavez was then buried at the union's
headquarters in la paz where his grave
in the following weeks and months and
years
would draw thousands of visitors
and where memorials at his gravesite
would serve as gathering places and
gathering times in which activists from
around the country and even around the
world
have met to call for new policies and
new campaigns
while the image of chavez has
increasingly become a rallying point for
latinos generally for civil rights
campaigns for diversity issues
caesar had quite mixed feelings about
putting himself forward as the face of
the farmworker movement while he was
alive as i've already said
trained as a community organizer in the
saul olinsky tradition
he warned others about the dangers of
charismatic leadership during his
younger years
and he worked hard throughout the
nineteen seventies in the nineteen
eighties to train farm workers modest
people as lawyers as community activists
as public spokespersons in ways that he
hoped would decenters the decenter the
public's focus on him
but since his death there can be no
doubt that the ufw leadership has
promoted chavez's memorialization
vigorously
through postage stamps and through the
renaming of schools linking the
organization's reputation today
and its success today
to its long-dead president
a community of memory has also formed
among one-time volunteers
for the ufw
people who ran the boycotts of the 60s
and the 70s and the 80s who found one
another online and have put together a
remarkable archive on documenting their
history and certainly some of the talk
of chavez today has something to do with
this very impressive archival project
that you see down at the bottom
and chavez's one-time lieutenants
those who worked with him and for him in
the union from the 1960s into the 1990s
have often operated in his name in the
last 20 years
first among them
is dolores huerta the second most
powerful figure in the union from the
1960s into the early 1990s and still
a major activist around labor
immigration feminist and lgbt issues
today
she received the presidential medal of
freedom in may 2012
at age 83 she's still traveling
more than 150 days out of the year
but other uh
activists and policy makers schooled by
the united farm workers have also been
key to latino and u.s politics since
1993
eliseo medina
until about two weeks ago second in
command of the service employees
industrial industrial union
marshall gans of harvard university who
engineered obama's wisconsin strategy
in 2008 here on the left
miguel contreras and antonio viaragosa
head of the los angeles county
federation of labor
and the past mayor of los angeles former
u.s secretary of labor hilda solis and
many more
were schooled in the campaigns
of the united farm workers in advance of
chavez's death
and then there are the everyday people
around the country with posters and
other images of chavez on the walls of
their homes or their workplaces or
people who have created altars in his
name at holiday time or around his
birthday or at political events
with these images in mind
let me get back now to chavez's life
work
leaving the gravesite leaving the altars
and leaving the passions expressed
around his body in 1993 behind
to reflect on the ways in which chavez
had helped to build a movement
shaped by religiosity that would
eventually treat him as a martyr or a
prophet or a saint after his death
what i want to say today is not so much
about theology
i'm no theologian there are others in
the room who are
nor is it meant to validate any way of
thinking about what's sacred what's
providential or what's divine i'm
certainly not arguing that chavez
actually was a saint although some do
far from it
but if there's one thing i've learned in
my recent research it's that the ufw was
and is
in many senses a religious movement in
the eyes of many of its core adherents
and that the farm workers union and
particularly its now dead president
continue to be invoked with a sort of
holy reverence
and awe
his effect on the contemporary civil
rights movement and on the immigrant
rights movement today in 2013 has for me
i think
religious overtones in the way he is
discussed
the connections made
to gandhi to king to others are no doubt
part of this and those connections made
between farmworker campaigns in
california and elsewhere and global
struggles for justice emerged thanks to
chavez and other activists over time
even 20 years after his death
many major political debates today that
surround latinos and that surround farm
workers continue to run through this
person what would caesar do
about immigration reform about
affirmative action or bilingual
education environmental cleanup
campaigns
the establishment of ethnic studies
electoral redistricting and on and on
if there is a modern latino saint from
the late 20th century one who's invoked
if not prayed to though some do
and one whose powerful legacies are
still channeled today in secular
campaigns in secular campaigns that seek
to add an otherworldly dimension to
liberation struggles that figure i think
is chavez
now there are good reasons for
foregrounding
the religious
history of the united farm workers union
that caesar ran
recall
that the union's roots lay in the 1950s
and early 1960s not within the
declarations of secularism that defined
the left around 1968.
the ufw was earlier the ufw emerged in
the season of the second vatican council
in an era in which latin american social
movements
far to the south of california were
redefining issues related to the church
to jesus as liberator and to the meaning
of justice on earth
churches influenced mexicans and mexican
americans far more than labor unions
during these years during the truman and
eisenhower and kennedy years
chavez himself was radicalized in part
through the teaching of a teachings of a
progressive parish priest in northern
california whom he met in 1952
a priest who insisted that chavez read
the papal encyclicals on social justice
a priest who traveled throughout the
state arguing for farm workers rights to
unionize already and who wrote letters
of introduction
to other priests around california on
caesar's behalf explaining that this
young organizer was a good catholic and
not a communist
and caesar was very religious as a young
man and he would remain so throughout
his life
a devout catholic a person deeply
engaged with
the politics of the catholic church but
also of ecumenism and ecumenical
thinking as it was developing in the
1960s and 1970s a self-taught student
of world religions who was interested in
jainism and hinduism very interested in
judaism interested in most of the major
world religions who became fascinated
with new religious practices emerging in
california during these years of
movements like est or synon
and who also considered himself in his
later years to be something of a faith
healer
who in his last decade or so of life
believed that he was like his own
grandmother
a curandero a cure a healer who was able
to lay hands on people and to make them
well and there are many stories
that people
who think reverentially about caesar
tell about caesar's supposedly healing
people who were sick in the union
at the very moment in the early 1960s in
which the bishops began gathering in
rome to debate the reforms that would
increase the role of the laity in local
parishes
scale back the ether asso the presumed
authority of priests
de-emphasize the latin mass and call for
new ecumenical connections
chavez moved to the central valley of
california to begin organizing uh
agricultural workers that was 1962 as
i've said the same year in which chavez
and many other mexican americans who'd
been involved in california politics
took began to take a weekend spiritual
retreats meant for spanish-speaking men
throughout the world retreats that were
called the cursillo and that began in
spain
retreats in which chavez and others
devoted themselves to considering the
connections between faith and social
justice and their own community
responsibilities as men
caesar did his three-day spiritual
retreat in the small california town of
readley where he reflected on the themes
of piety
study and action
his notes about his time at the retreat
center include musings on quote
the social order it must be changed our
faith must influence it unions
organizations clubs etc
he entered that retreat experience
hoping to find a small group organizing
model that he could then use to educate
farm workers
in union principles and he spent a good
deal of time at the retreat center on
that long weekend writing the
constitution for the labor organization
that he would go on to found
he left that all-male gathering with new
ideas too about self self sacrifice
ideas that would lead him by the late
1960s to argue against the masculinist
politics that had come to define black
and brown power
quote to be a man is to suffer for
others
god help us to be men
he wrote
a few days after leaving the retreat
house he would organize a group of farm
workers to take over a routine state
department of industrial welfare meeting
in fresno this was his first victory as
a farm labor unionist
chavez also left that retreat house
singing
de colores
one of the fundamental anthems of the
farm labor movement and of the chicano
movement that followed it and a fixture
in preschool world music curricula
today i'm sure some of you know that
cursillo song cursillo song
about the beauties of the rural world
served its purposes well
chavez had been looking to infuse the
1950s mexican-american politics with new
life and with passion
groups like the community service
organization and lulac of the past
decade had little of the raucous spirit
that had defined popular front groups
during the 1930s and the 1940s
where the earlier left had danced
the 1950s crowd seemed insistent on
robert's rules of order
chavez wanted to import into the farm
labor movement
something of the emotional abandon that
he had seen and heard in mexican
pentecostal churches and
african-american baptist churches in
small rural towns
the place of music in union meetings
of linking hands to sing
mexican corridos written about local
growers or california politicians
or the singing of nosotros venceremos we
shall overcome in spanish or
welgan general
general strike a song brought back from
cuba to california in the early 1960s
turned chavez's organization into more
of a camp meeting than anything mexican
americans had seen anywhere in the
united states for decades
this fact made the united farm workers
a demonstrably new social movement
one that took a new direction from the
1950s organization precisely because it
attempted to mobilize people's spirits
in new ways
spirit was an important keyword for the
movement chavez spoke openly about the
spirit of the mexican revolution of
achieving the justice promised to
activists immigrant grandparents who had
fought with sapata or with via during
the 1910s and after 1962
chavez organized through religion
speaking about rights and spirit
conveyed by god
and emphasizing
that rural unionization fulfilled the
mission of many faith communities to
work for justice on this earth
by framing political debates and demands
at least in part through religious
language
chavez hoped to stress
to farm workers their own basic dignity
and to emphasize
an emphasis excuse me that contradicted
the 20th century's ongoing cultural
representations of rural
laboring agriculturalists as beasts of
burden
as faceless even in the most muckraking
photographs as content with their lot or
too frightened to do anything about
their situations
dignity and respect
were key words for the movement
unmediated
by distinctions of race or gender or
citizenship
they called upon audiences of farm
workers to struggle on behalf of the
bill of rights and what they were owed
by the government but more importantly
to exceed those promises
following the emphasis of of the
prophets chavez saw himself
telling groups that he that while he
might not see the signing of good labor
contracts anytime soon his followers
would one day see that promised land
these in chavez's
eyes were references to biblical time
he told the brazilian catholic educator
and urban activist paolo frere
that quote
the difference between the growers and
the farm workers union
is that the growers have money and the
workers have time
we don't have exceptional skills or
finances but we have a lot of dedicated
people and a lot of time
in the hands of the of chavez and of the
ufw religion
combined with dedication was meant to
shape consciousness raising to bring a
new consciention
to rural people
the poor the excluded the racialized the
immigrant
who had rarely expressed a public policy
public politics before
chavez contended that farm workers
who came to recognize their core dignity
would no longer take for granted their
maltreatment in american society
as their common sense about the world
changed
chavez told an anti-vietnam rally
mexican-americans and filipinos in
california would say no to quote a life
of economic slavery and they would turn
quote their sacrifices and their
suffering into a powerful campaign for
dignity and for justice
this was social theory a theory of
political action
framed by dignity and by suffering as
commonly understood catholic principles
chavez did all this in ecumenical ways
building on the coalitions that he had
helped to forge during the 1950s that
connected mexican-american civil rights
to quaker and jewish activists statewide
and that had emerged at the local level
in neighborhoods like boyle heights
california where jews and
mexican-americans interacted as
neighbors from the 1930s into the 1950s
but while activists in the 1950s had
taken money and support from
non-catholics
chavez and others during the 60s and 70s
actually brought other faith traditions
into the movement itself
a star of david hung and in the union's
headquarters
a family of spanish-speaking farm
workers who ran boycott operations in
far away pittsburgh
named their newly born daughter shalom
and union meetings featured invocations
from protestant and catholic officials
in pushing for ecumenical coalition
building by the way
these farmworker activists fought
differently than some others some of
their contemporaries in the emerging
chicano movement those who were
distancing themselves
from black churches or who followed the
lead of some in the black or brown power
movements in blaming urban minorities
impoverishment on jews
the ufw would have none of that so by
contrast the ufw under chavez's
leadership worked hard to link faith in
its broadest forms and action
chavez and others involved in the grape
strike that began in september of 1965
worked hard to involve religious leaders
largely as a way to broaden the struggle
beyond repressive small town california
invited to delano from congregations
throughout the country in the early
months of the grape strike
ministers and priests and rabbis nearly
always left ready to announce that a new
social struggle one that many believed
carried forward the best traditions of
the african-american freedom struggles
had now appeared on the west coast
these visitors affirmed the spiritual
bases of the struggle and their own
place within it
one ecumenical delegation declared in
the mid-1960s that quote we reject the
heresy that churches and synagogues are
to be concerned only with so-called
spiritual matters the suffering of farm
workers and of their children cries to
heaven and demands the attention of men
of conscience
a new york times
reporter called these religious leaders
chavez's quote secret weapon
and chavez would later admit
that churches had proven far more
helpful than students or labor unionists
in his organization's early struggles
when
six months after the start of the grape
strike
the union marched more than 300 miles
from delano to the state capital of
sacramento to publicize their demands it
was no accident then
that they marched during lent and that
they held the state's largest to date
latino political rally on the capitol
lawn here
in on easter sunday of 1966
their 10 000 marchers ambling up highway
99
did so behind the flag of the virgin of
guadalupe
an icon that had
since the 1920s since the the era of the
cristero revolt in the in mexico
rarely ever been used by progressive
civil rights forces in the u.s until
1966
but they commit but they also
communicated a deep commitment to
ecumenism and a coalition building which
was equally new in the west
announcing that activists who'd begun to
feel marginalized
by the rise of black power in the south
would be welcome
in the california farm worker struggle
members of jewish community relations
councils from the san francisco bay area
and other marchers took part on this
march in religious services
co-celebrated by priests and by rabbis
and it was a california rabbi who gave
the benediction at the end of the easter
rally lotting chavez as a quote
self-effacing but incredibly efficient
modern-day non-violent emiliano zapata
it was the language of non-violence
combined with the union's insistence on
penitence and on pilgrimage that deeply
touched many religious and non-religious
supporters during the mid and late 1960s
chavez is fast for non-violence in 1968
the union's most important publicity
moment by far
during the 1960s established chavez's
image as a saint in the global media
through the circulation above all of the
image of the emaciated mexican-american
alongside bobby kennedy
at the mass concluding this fast
the assassination of martin luther king
less than a month
after chavez's 25-day fast ended brought
the ufw new adherence as many believe
that this farmworker leader was now the
one carrying forward the spirit
of the sclc's apostle of non-violence
it was the language of fasting
movement activists always insisted that
was critical to the organization's
success
that term fasting evoked penance
self-denial efforts at bodily and moral
regulation
and was not intended
they said to make explicit demands on
growers or others this was not in other
words a hunger strike that was would
only end with some union victory
for some
these fasts seemed like modest gestures
but chavez clearly meant the fast in
part as what he called following gandhi
moral jujitsu
an effort to aggravate the sense of
grower's power
by displaying your own relative weakness
and at every turn
the union took pains throughout these
fasts to send a broadly inclusive
message
the 1968 celebration here in which
chavez ended the 25-day fast at robert
kennedy's side
a gathering of 9 000 in delano opened
with a hebrew prayer a protestant sermon
and then the catholic mass
so this i think was part
of the political brilliance
of the united farm workers
the visible practice of penance and of
self-denial proved more responsible than
any other factor for the success of the
great boycott nationally and
internationally
just as thousands marched with him in
1966 and in many later marches
hundreds arrived to visit chavez's
bedside to help care for him each day
they hoped
during his fasts
in the 1960s 70s 80s and into the early
90s as he was still fasting
calling attention to this discursive
form of politics
shouldn't discount of course the hard
battles of boycott organizers who spent
years on picket lines and in supermarket
parking lots trying to urge shoppers to
forego certain purchases in the interest
of helping poor farm workers but it does
suggest that they and others out there
in the parking lots and on the picket
lines depended very heavily on a
discourse about sacrifice and about
humility that was meant both to
emphasize on the one hand the humanity
of rural workers
and on the other to define the roles of
urban consumers
in achieving social justice
part of the message sent by chavez and
other ufw organizers during this period
was that however corrupt the national
policies of of of the united states
might be
americans and others could follow the
higher laws that ought to govern
humanity religious laws
through particular acts of conscience
that would have real effects for those
living in rural areas
the religious subtexts of the grape and
lettuce boycotts were fundamentally
useful because they helped the ufw claim
a moral terrain that rose above the
complicated political economies of
western agriculture that commanded moral
attention
the political economies of agriculture
were becoming far more complicated by
the 1970s than they had been in the
1960s and growers and others who opposed
the united farm workers did their best
to accentuate that sense of complexity
rival teamster unionists many of them
mexican-americans
some of them actually farm workers
won many contracts of their own at the
ufw's expense during the 70s and leaders
of the teamsters union argued that all
of chavez's harping in the public sphere
was simply about a jurisdictional battle
over representation between rival unions
in other words chavez's was a story of
sour grapes
in the face of such charges
penance and modesty and devotion proved
all the more important to union rhetoric
it was the sincerity and devotion of
chavez the person the man
willing to give up his body that was
meant to stand in and and prove the
sincerity and devotion of the union at
large
in engaging farm workers and consumers
and policy makers
the union spoke a religious language of
rights and responsibilities
according to the language of the boycott
american consumers us
need to imagine their our own solidarity
with poor workers laboring far away in
the grape and lettuce fields of the
golden state consumption is a matter of
conscience the union insists
the produce aisle in our local grocery
store is a political space
and we deny ourselves certain pleasures
like grapes in the hope of making a
better world for them
chavez combined an insistence on the
powerful possibilities of dignity and of
suffering and sacrifice with a modern
eucharistic reading of agriculture in
california a reading in which chavez
linked the food shared by consumers
purchased in the grocery store
consumed at our tables
to the bodies of workers whose
sufferings in california and elsewhere
echoed christ's sufferings
this was apparent across the 1970s and
the 1980s
when the united farm workers made
workers health just as critical as wages
and contracts in their social justice
campaigns
key to these efforts
were the union's focus on the
short-handled hoe
shown here
that instrument of labor control and
bodily discipline used in many row crops
throughout the 20th century
work that chavez tellingly called quote
the most crucifying work of all
degrading the most vicious exploitation
of the human body
he and others in the union insisted
repeatedly that consumers and outside
supporters could remove that cross
that farmworkers bore
helping laborers live like people
instead of like body machines
quote we have soul
and god has given us dignity he told a
group in calexico
quote but the growers still consider us
only agricultural implements
here in this park today we make a solemn
promise to enjoy a rightful part of the
riches of this rich land and to throw
off the yoke of being considered as
agricultural implements
another key to understanding
the cultural politics of chavez's world
was the union's effort to draw attention
to rampant pesticide poisoning in rural
communities and particularly to the
cancer clusters in towns like mcfarland
california
the union coded these as threats not
just to the farm workers who live there
but ultimately to everyone in the united
states to all consumers of california
produce
if the bodies of farm workers were
exposed to parathyan to ddt
or to other quote economic poisons as
chavez called them
then those chemicals just as surely will
find their way into middle class homes
on the east coast
this critical argument
connected the fates of workers bodies
with those of far away consumers this
emphasis which ultimately drew
from chavez's catholic thinking about
the body of christ which links all
people in some mystical fashion
here not just through the eucharist
through the food but through the sharing
of california produce what comes to our
table remained the critical subtext of
hundreds of union mailings of flyers and
speeches during the late 20th century
and came to inspire a great deal of art
as well
all of this
all of these campaigns this religious
rhetoric proved enormously effective for
the union at least for a time
the language of conscience and of
justice
for forced george meaney and other labor
leaders to invest millions of dollars
into farmworker unionization despite
their doubts about it
and about chavez
the catholic bishops became strong
supporters
east coast rabbis shut down great
purchases in new york city in boston and
elsewhere
hundreds of synagogues and temples
across the nation
refused to use non-union grapes for a
sacramental wine
and the massachusetts board of rabbis
published a formal legal opinion based
on talmudic prince precedence that
supported the boycott of grapes
deeply immersed one leader of the
american jewish community committee
called all this quote a model of
sophisticated effective cooperation
between catholics protestants and jews
joining hands in the common work of
social justice
chavez joked that he more than anyone
else was responsible to get for getting
many of these people to talk with one
another for the first time across
religious lines
now of course the site of roman callers
of nuns of rabbis and ministers on union
picket lines drove growers to
distraction
one anti-ufw group declared quote
ministers of the gospel are the greatest
dupes for the socialistic and
communistic manipulators in california
union opponents
hired uh skilled and expensive public
relations experts in new york city to
craft a portrait of a more devious and
more militant and entirely unspiritual
cesar chavez
these portraits called chavez a false
prophet and questioned his unionist
credentials
quote his appeal is primarily racial
one grower told the new york times
they accused him of violating their
constitutional rights and they charged
chavez with harassing innocent
unsuspecting housewives coast to coast
who simply wanted to feed their families
conservative spokespeople for some of
the growers
some of these spokespeople mexican
americans went on national speaking
tours to denounce what they called quote
the chavez community forces
and the union's quote black bird of
death
now those arguments those counter
arguments about religiosity never really
dislodged chavez from his moral perch
during his life
reviewing the african-american freedom
struggle of the post-world war ii period
historian david chappelle
has argued that quote white supremacists
in the south
failed to get their churches to give
their cause active support that was
their achilles heel
and i think in much the same way
growers and teamsters found it all but
impossible to sway many religious
leaders into anti-chavez positions
few prominent national religious
organizations refused to support chavez
during his lifetime
the decision of the southern california
arizona united methodist church was
typical
members of that annual conference
declared their support for the union
based on chavez's earnest christian
stalwart character
chavez's connections with religiosity
did prompt real controversy on the left
traditional unionists often hated these
signs of religiosity and all the god
talk in the movement
some young activists believed
religiosity had no place in the
organization at all
and sometimes travis got himself in
trouble for speaking about things he
didn't understand
following the start of the yom kippur
war
many criticized chavez's controversial
statement on israel that urged quote all
our brothers and sisters in the
farmworker movement and all people of
goodwill throughout the world to stand
with israel in its struggle to
live and to be free
still despite this controversy
from 1965 into the 1990s the ufw was
able to occupy high moral ground on
issues related to labor relations
immigration and more
making the organization what the afl-cio
would later call quote the conscience of
the labor movement
when chavez was imprisoned for two weeks
for calling a nationwide lettuce boycott
workers created altars and held 24-hour
vigils outside the monterey county jail
catholic school kids wrote chava's
letters of support at the prompting of
the nuns
ethel kennedy attended mass outside the
jail coretta scott king bestowed her
blessing on chavez quote
two thousand years ago in bethlehem a
man spoke to the lowly about poverty and
human dignity jesus of nazareth was
crucified but he is here with us in
salinas today
because the lowly need him again
during another struggle near near
bakersfield an elderly dorothy day was
among 60 religious leaders jailed for
participating in ufw picket lines she
announced that quote when you see
churchmen in jail you feel it has become
a real christianity
and rome's approval certainly helped
in chavez's private papal audience
in september of 1974
pope paul vi called him quote a loyal
son of the catholic church and a
distinguished leader and representative
of the mexican-american community
and the pontiff indicated quote we're
all indeed grateful to mr chavez for the
lesson which he brings to our attention
so i hope by now that i've convinced you
that chavez's movement
this foundational piece of modern latino
politics was religious to the core and
may still be
and that you might be able to see why it
provided a language of dignity of
liberation of solidarity
even as it provided a framework for
institutional and individual support by
outsiders
chavez's insistence
that god is on the side of the poor
that what seems impossible to achieve
will actually be possible
that legal provisions alone don't
capture the limit of what's right and
just
and that we're intimately connected with
those who are unrecognized in our
society
these are powerful starting points
i think you'll agree for social
movements
and they remain so today
if you listen closely
you can hear echoes of these arguments i
think in the many boycott campaigns
ongoing in the 21st century since the
early 2000s
you can certainly identify these strains
in the immigration rights movement which
produced in 2006 the largest public
demonstrations in u.s history and which
prompted 20 new haveners just this week
including yale students to submit to
arrest in washington dc
and you can hear it in the democratic
party's efforts to connect to capture
the latino vote
most famously in barack obama's adoption
of the united farm workers phrase
si se
as yes we can
onwards
this phrase suggests the people will be
heard
nothing is impossible
the future is bright
have courage
all of which brings us back
in what may seem a paradoxical way
to the death of chavez in 1993.
his gravesite
which is also the ufw's working center
in keene california not far from
bakersfield
was declared
a national monument by president obama
last fall
it was a nod
to the unrecognized importance of latino
history as united states history
it was an acknowledgment that the union
and its supporters had played an
important role in electing obama twice
but it was also an affirmation of
chavez's perceived importance today in
the 21st century as something like a
beacon an inspiration a model or a guide
standing not far from chavez's grave
exactly almost exactly a year ago
president obama
declared
that quote
the truth is we would not be here if it
weren't for caesar
and that the message that chesiva caesar
conveys for the 21st century is in many
respects a religious one
quote
every time somebody's son or daughter
comes and learns about the history of
this movement
i want them to know that our journey is
never hopeless our work is never done
i want them to learn about a small man
guided by enormous faith
in a righteous cause a loving god
the dignity of every human being
i want them to remember that true
courage is revealed when the night is
darkest and the resistance is strongest
and we somehow find it within ourselves
to stand up for what we believe in
president obama
in declaring this a national landmark
concluded that quote
our world is a better place because
caesar chavez decided to change it let's
honor his memory but most importantly
let's live up to his example
and in the phrase and in the language
that perhaps best suggests chavez's
importance for the 20th 21st century
obama concluded his remarks with
si se puede
thank you